bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi deo sono farisei e oggi
siamo in un nuovo video dove parlo di
cose allo ragazzi questo video molto
importante siccome ragazzi ho notato che
nel tempo notato questa cosa molti di
voi
seguono pagine di instagram di facebook
di twitter dopo il 2 con cui viene il 3
io non lo so ancora fare seguono le
persone che si chiamano fa vigenti v
oppure lorenzo studi oppure fa vj
credendo che sia io però non sono io
queste persone vengono comunemente
chiamate fake perché in persona nono
youtuber una popstar un pornodivo
fingendo di essere lui quando non sono
lui il problema nasce quando queste
persone vanno a dire cose
fingendosi dj in questo caso cose che io
magari non ho mai detto ma non cose
cattive però per dire a domani uscirà un
video di chi fa quando mai ho fatto fifa
io almeno se devi fare il fake fallo
bene quindi ragazzi oggi sono qui per
dirvi quali sono i miei sociali unici
social che io possiedo oltre youtube se
lo vogliamo contare come social sono
facebook
instagram twitter e anche se questo lo
vogliamo chiamare social spotify il mio
social più seguito quello che utilizzo
di più dopo youtube lo dovevo più
seguito anche dopo youtube e instagram
dove all 1,7 milioni di followers chiara
ferragni può accompagnare sono veramente
sono veramente tantissimi vi ringrazio
perché siete proprio tanti tanti i fa
piacere che vi interessi di io che
pubblico le foto mentre sono al cesso
dopo instagram o la pagina di facebook
quella che è rimasta sempre in
descrizione per questi quattro anni dopo
facebook o twitter
e qui arriviamo al punto twitter io l'ho
aperto solo recentemente perché quando
uscì twitter ai tempi io usavo già
facebook e twitter
ecco vedi avere i social [ __ ] [ __ ]
diceva utilizzato facebook quindi
twitter non lo usavo semplicemente nel
tempo twitter è diventato indispensabile
per dialogare per scrivere cazzate alle
2 di notte quando vuoi condividere un
tuo pensiero con qualcuno che ti ascolti
questo è quello che fai su twitter di
base dopo ben 4 anni ho deciso di aprire
twitter il problema dove sta che fa vj
fa vj tv pa vj official fan
descritto fa vj favi gestito favi dei
quali già iscritto più di pai erano
tutti i guanti presi perché appunto ci
sono questi fake che mi impersonano
allora che cosa ho fatto ho chiesto a
twitter
senti ma non potete recuperarmi profilo
di fa vj tv che era un ragazzo che si
fingeva me questo è stato quello che gli
ho chiesto è la risposta è stata se
quindi twitter stesso mia recuperi che
ringrazio mi ha recuperato il profilo di
questo ragazzo che si fingeva a me
chiamato fabici tv ed adesso questo
profilo twitter ce l'ho io è la cosa
divertente che questo account è stato
rubato da me ho rubato un account
praticamente ma non è la prima volta che
succede perché instagram che è il mio
primo social è un account rubato quando
io ho deciso di aprirmi instagram
anche lì c'erano già dei fake miei e
ovviamente il fake fa vj mi aveva già
[ __ ] l'account con il mio nickname
quindi non potevo usarlo io ai tempi
però quando creato instagram 01 youtube
è abbastanza piccolo quindi non potevo
andare da instagram è dire ciao sono fa
vj mi date quel profilo che in teoria
sono io fa vj
fatto sta che aveva rubato un fan e io
ho rubato a lui il profilo nel senso o
hackerato un profilo di instagram quindi
ragazzi mio profilo instagram fa vj
questo qui è bizzarro perché a tipo è
verificato a 2 milioni di follower ma è
un profilo a chiarato nel senso che non
era mio non l'ho creato io ho rubato uno
che me lo aveva rubato ai tempi ed è una
storia fantastica perché due dei miei
tre social sono rubati fa vj e un ladro
per la calre la cosa ho fatto ti ho
detto vabbè me ne creerà uno nuovo di
instagram però dai proviamo un paio di
password magari mi va bene cosa potrà
mettere come password uno che si chiama
l'account fa vj fa vj figurati se scrivo
la password fa dj cosa vuoi che va
brutto fei che in utile grazie di avermi
tenuto al sicuro al sicuro l'account fa
vj per poi farmelo rubare per poi
verificarlo e diventare la nuova cara
delle vigne e invece subito è stato
alquanto strano perché ho preso il
profilo ho iniziato a twittare io ero la
prima cosa che ho scritto è stata ciao
ragazzi per quello che ci stava prima
era un fake
adesso sono io quindi ragazzi e questo
video ora per
dirvi che in realtà i miei social sono
quattro ce l'avete seguirmi li trovate
in descrizione c'è anche spotify per chi
è veramente ogni settimana ogni tot di
tempo vado in fissa con una canzone
nuova no e quindi ho la mia playlist
quindi se mi seguite sulla mia playlist
ogni settimana vedete quali sono le
canzoni con le quali sta andando in
fissa io così condivido tutta la mia
music con tutti quanti i ragazzi follo a
temi su tutti quanti i social che sono
una persona bella soprattutto fashion
volevo concludere il discorso ragazzi
dicendo vi diffidate ma questo non solo
nel mio caso da tutte le persone che si
fingono fa vj anche compresi quelli che
mettevano le gemme di clash royale nei
commenti che tra l'altro sono spariti
dopo che ho fatto quel video bravi kakà
soft dei nerd in fidate appunto da tutte
le persone che si fingono che pubblicano
con la scritta fa vj of avg tv se non
sono su questi social per i ragazzi e
questo era per aggiornare all'ultima
roba dimenticato quanto 9 che dovevo
dire ho cambiato la descrizione dei
video che da 4 anni 4 anni da quattro
anni a questa parte è rimasta sempre la
stessa ed era tipo pagina facebook
ufficiale di fa vj adesso che ho
aggiornato tutti quanti social ho
aggiornato anche la descrizione di ogni
video i più aggiunto un paio di frasi
carine perché sono una persona simpatica
e i ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
cosi
l'argomento è un mi piace anche ai
social che come in ogni vita a trattare
descrizione
questa è la nuova frase di chiusura che
ho dovuto sostituire perché prima dicevo
solo facebook quando effettivamente ne
ho tanti altri la famiglia dice che ha
cambiato la fra chi non sono più belli
clinica senza averci discreti di ci
vediamo al prossimo lido bella ragazzi
[Musica]